[Music]
with the 60th pick in the
2014 NBA Draft the San Antonio Spurs
select Jeremy Brown from Oklahoma City a
this guy and he's
[Applause]
terrible good night everyone and thanks
for
[Applause]
coming
there's my guy your guy your guy your
guy was told by his agent that he was
going to be a late first round maybe
second round draft pick your guy
supposed to be in New York with the rest
of those Chumps your guy your guy about
to blow his freaking lid cuz his dream
of being an NBA it's still just a dream
hey chill man I know this isn't how we
wanted it to go down believe me like I
told you you're my last best hope at the
agency if you wash out I wash out with
you
but I was
thinking maybe this was the best thing
that could have happened to you how you
figure that genus better to go undrafted
and have a choice than to be picked late
by a stacked playoff team where your
chances of making the team are about as
high as my chances of dating a
supermodel which despite my contagious
charm are pretty freaking Slim So what's
the move
man this just affects our timing okay
you just got to keep working hard and be
ready injuries overhyped draft picks
sooner or later players are going to
wash out and they are going to call you
you hear
me yes I hear you
good remember Jordan was cut from his
high school basketball team and made
fools pay for it the rest of his career
use the draft day slight as motivation a
chip on your shoulder at the beginning
of a long journey and like every Journey
this one begins with a single step so
your first step is to keep working hard
and we'll find you a home before you
know
it all right man I'm believing in you
bro make it
[Music]
happen